[Music]
good
okay um well i will just
i will just like read my little
introduction here
okay hello plastic pills listeners this
is victor brazoni here again with matt
mcmanus bringing you another
politics-focused micro dose
this time the topic is marx and
liberalism and liberal rights
to help us in this discussion we have
igor and actually i just realized i
probably should have asked you how to
pronounce your last name
before we did this but do you want to
give it do you want to do it for me
shortcut broad would be probably the
best most feasible
okay oh god yeah that's that's a
separate session on
how to pronounce my last name honestly
yeah sorry okay
let's just keep that in okay yeah igor
received his phd
uh in political science from the
university of toronto and in fact his
supervisor
peggy cohen is the same supervisor that
i have currently have right
your supervisor was peggy yes alongside
simone chambers who's now at uh
university of california irvine
oh right okay yeah uh so igor is also
currently adjunct professor
in the ethics society and law program at
trinity college in the university of
toronto
um and as i understand it you're
teaching a pretty inhumane number of
classes right now
four did you say or five yes uh in
addition to the trinity college program
also i have a lectureship appointment at
utm
wow so that's why there are many uh
courses
uh being taught by me this time around
and i hope and
the students are benefiting and not
suffering from that yeah
and of course all on the computer so you
must it you sit in front of your screen
like all the time i guess these that's
right
that's right all right so uh zeitgeist
yeah um igor recently published a very
interesting book
revisiting marx's critique of liberalism
our own matt mcmanus
writing for jacobin called it an
excellent book that deserves a large
audience
lincoln's description uh you recently
said igor
that your book intentionally seeks to
provoke liberals
marxists and critical theorists of all
stripes to revisit established
orthodoxies and assumptions
and that there has been a peculiar
convergence of interpretations
concerning marx's supposed anti-law and
anti-rights views
across interpretive and political
divides um so yeah this is
a provocative goal indeed i think uh in
the online politics twitter youtube
sphere that
we at plastic pills sometimes find
ourselves in there is certainly a strong
tendency on both the right and
especially the left
to see marxism as hostile to formal
rights
you know online leftists i think seem to
see this as a sort of badge of honor
since rights and laws are just tools for
the capitalist class to protect their
private property
or something dirty libs like maybe me
and matt latch onto
admittedly my own hostility to marxism
tends to be related to the assertion
that the state will wither away
the idea that this is desirable or a
coherent goal i've always sort of had a
problem with part of my objection to
that i think is that times
um at times like this we find ourselves
uh you know institutions are being
threatened um
changing in reaction to changing moods
and cultural shift and it seems like
strong institutions
like rights and laws are useful for
certain problems
and although i kind of hate the
political spectrum or describing myself
on the political spectrum um i suppose
if pushed i would place myself
reluctantly somewhere like
rawls's liberal socialism but now it
sounds like your book is
telling me that at least part of my
version of marxism is maybe based
on a misunderstanding perhaps we could
begin by having you tell us
what that central misunderstanding is um
so yeah igor well thanks victor for
organizing this session
and to matt again for his uh review in
the jacobin which is
very well written and i think balanced
and fair and has given me
an opportunity to also reflect on where
i should move forward
in the sense that there obviously are
loose ends you know in every in every
book
uh and so i thank you match for that um
uh a lot of what you said victor uh
resonates with the inspiration of the
motivation for for the book
in fact uh it first occurred to me that
this is a topic worth writing about
after having a conversation with a
another committee member of mine
who teaches in the law faculty namely
alan breuner
and this was a course i was taking with
him a terrific course
which he used to teach and unfortunately
no longer does called the hegel's
political
theory the political thought of hegel
and we read
of course the phenomenology of spirit
and um
uh and the philosophy of right and might
as well put in a plug
for allen's book called the owl and the
rooster hegel's transformative political
science was
cambridge university press there's
the paperback edition i think just came
out so it's significantly cheaper
i'm sure alan will appreciate the plug
if and when he does
uh tune into this wonderful podcast but
basically we were going through you know
the typical uh
struggle in this course you get the vast
majority of students either
you know uh really interested in hegel
or you know the vast majority really
interested in marx
and uh hegel's influence on marx and uh
i kept you know asking alan brunner
about you know
some of the limitations of hegel's
approach particularly in his discussion
of civil society and ultimately of the
state the tension between civil society
and the state
and it seemed as though helen was
getting increasingly tired of my
questions and barrage
and he just you know front and said he
said igor but don't you want to have
rights
you know aren't you worried about the
dictatorship of the proletariat
and then you have articulated victory
just using other words effectively
and that got me thinking got me thinking
about the importance
right of trying to come to grips with
that channel it's a challenge that you
hear
you know from honest liberals i don't
know about dirty liberals
in that there is a danger with the
concentration of political power and few
fewer hands
when there are no institutional forms of
mediation
that can strain uh you know the power of
governments
right and this is something that i think
is very important to the liberal
tradition
aside from its commitment to the at
least formal
uh equality of individuals as bearers of
rights
and it really got me thinking about this
problem
something that i took for granted at
first to be honest i thought that this
seems silly that
you know marx marx's social political
thought
uh which is oriented towards the idea
that the free development of each is the
condition for the free development wall
wouldn't secure a place or a space for
individual
self-assertion in the emancipated
society of the future
but at that point in time as a fourth
year undergraduate student
you know still trying to figure out what
i want to do with my life that's still
the case by the way
although i'm not a fourth year
undergraduate student for the record
um for our listeners uh it really got me
thinking
about why i took it for granted that
there would be
such a sphere a protected sphere as
liberals would put it for individual
self-assertion and that it would take
some institutional form
right rather than an unmediated right
relation between individuals in this
collective
um but i didn't have the evidence at the
time uh
and i didn't want to make it you know i
didn't want to beg beg the question
and i didn't want to start with the
conclusion i wanted to actually
ask myself the questions that don
bruckner posed to me namely
what is the value of rights and is
whether or not the rights of discourse
or rights talk
is compatible with marxist social and
political thought and in order to do
that
i had to return to his really early
writings
right to track his sort of intellectual
journey
and that brought me to his articles for
the uh
rhinest titan which is a radical you
know liberal i would say periodical you
have to understand in the context of the
time
right where the prussian institutions
were very much
in effect right and that region
cologne the rhino rhineland
actually you know as a consequence of
the napoleonic
heritage initially inherited some
liberal reforms but then they were sort
of
undermined and ultimately there was the
restoration of the prussian state
and what you see in these early uh
writings these articles for the um
rhinis title is marx taking seriously uh
the idea of law from the standpoint i
would argue as i do in the book of
rational law this
interpretation of mine was actually
influenced by another book that i had
read
by olufemi taiwan called legal
naturalism
marxist theory of law which tries to
show
that well i mean i disagree with his
interpretation alternate but it tries to
show that for marx
every mode of production has its own
nature right
uh obviously i there's there's an
important disagreement that i have with
taiwan but taiwa does an excellent job
showing why these early writings are so
important
and what ended up happening in the
marxist tradition is they're typically
ignored
this is the idealist marx this is the
marx who is still trying to come to
grips with his own views
and i think that's a mistake that's a
mistake because we have to understand
the context in which marx is writing
and it was uh with great intention that
i chose as the cover image for my book
uh you know you have the lady justice
right in the woods
and it's not just some wacky idea it
actually uh it was inspired by marx's
famous
article for the uh rhinos tyton the lawn
of thefts of wood or the wood theft law
where marx basically takes issue
with the transformation if you will in
property relations such that
wealthy landowners the forest owners as
he calls them
are able to use the state as a vehicle
not only for their own self-enrichment
but rather as a punitive mechanism
against the uh impoverished peasants
right who would customarily because of
their situation
gather fallen forest words right and so
that was criminalized
and what marx ends up saying there
because he still believes in this idea
of rational law
which he uses as a benchmark for saying
that some laws are just
others aren't just is that as soon as
the state
in this kind of you know liberal
rational state stoops solo
as to reduce all of its policies if you
will or most of its policies
to the whims and the interests of
private property that's when
it fails as a state and shows that law
is actually
mortal and can and and is quite
distracted destructive and he
cites as many of you who've seen the uh
the film directed by raul peck the young
marx
right it actually starts it starts with
that it starts with that scene
and mark's actually in the footnote
sites montesquieu talking about how
bad laws corrupt people right
so i started there and i began to see
that marx did in fact take right
seriously
some rights anyway and that that was you
know significant for his understanding
of freedom and how it develops or how it
is constrained
but then the next challenge of course
was oh okay so that's the really young
marks
then you have the problem which was
popularized by louis althouser
namely the epistemological break which
usually
is traced to 1845 or so when engels and
marx
wrote the german ideology one quick note
is that we typically treat the german
ideologies a canonical text
it's anything but that and this is
something that was recognized by marx
and engels
it was an incomplete text and when they
reflect on the angles in particular
they remind themselves of how zealous
and polemical they are
and in some in one letter in one letter
which i don't cite in my book brought to
my attention by dan goldstick
um engels basically says we would put
haina to shame
you know with his poetry given our
polemical style so it's important to
understand the context right
we have a tendency especially those you
know political theory
to read marx's and his works most of
which were not published as if they are
ready and complete works and they're not
there's a whole history of marxian
reception and that has colored our
interpretation of marks
so the next step was to show actually
that there is an important continuity
now with standing you know the
development of marxist thought him
becoming a materialist quote unquote
we'll see that that's very different
from you know habitian materialism for
example obvious materialism
and the french materialist marx because
of the influence of
idealism hegel's in particular really
emphasize the active sensuous
you know aspects of human life which
distinguishes him from other
materials and important ways but
basically what i wanted to do is to show
actually
notwithstanding you know his conversion
to materialism
it nonetheless leaves an important
functional and normative
role for rect and rect is very
complicated in german
as you may know it can include both law
and right as a kind of normative
standard
and so marx uses it in both senses
except when he refers to gazettes which
is positive law
or statement law so i was able to show
that in the works we take
for granted as demonstrating marx's
uh opposition to rights german ideology
capital
the grunderson and elsewhere actually
there's more than enough evidence that
points to the contrary
and i wanted to bring this evidence to
the fore so that readers can judge for
themselves
whether they can maintain this uh
interpretation in the end
right a lot of my critics well mostly
sympathetic critics
either on the liberal side and or the
marxist side some of them you know think
of themselves as liberal marxists
if you could put that together as they
say that you've gone too far in trying
to show that marx was you know
so in favor of right so in favor of law
that you
that comes at the expense of his
critique of of um
of of rights and of uh liberal bourgeois
law
you know and in some sense that's a
valid criticism i would argue but my
response has always been since my
doctoral thesis defense
to professor carol gould for whom i have
a lot of respect
um that the stick right has been pushed
so
far in one direction namely that marx is
hostile to rights to law and to justice
then i tried to you know change
the course of events so that at least
you know people think twice about uh
jumping to the conclusion and that's you
know readers of
in the history of political thought
students but ordinary people as well and
activists
to think twice before jumping to the
conclusion that there's no place
for these things in march of social
political thought
now i think i think i'll i'll leave it
at that so that we can have a
conversation
yeah yeah matt
no i want to say first off that i
thought your book was excellent and as
you pointed out a
very well needed uh corrective uh to
this kind of
emphasis um that a lot of people put on
marks is
hostility towards the state and the
hostility towards rights
the two problems that i had with marx's
approach to rights
prior to reading your book uh were as
follows right the first one was again
its commitment to the philosophy of
history
in lieu of normative argument and this
argument that there was
a teleological orientation towards
history that eventually things are going
to wither away
uh and this is and the commonest state
is going to emerge whether you want it
or not right
and i've always been a little bit
reticent of that and as i pointed out in
my review
i think this is the one thing where
maybe your book could have
spent a little bit more time addressing
these anxieties right but when it comes
to
my second anxiety which was well what
happens in the communist state or in a
marx estate
when things were there away and there's
no protection for individual rights you
do a fantastic job
of explaining why that wouldn't
necessarily be the case um in a marxist
framework
uh that actually there would be some
protections for individual rights um
but they'd be reframed uh in this more
democratic
uh and more egalitarian fashion uh and
candidly um i wouldn't have thought that
that would have been possible and that
somebody could change my mind on these
points but you made a very compelling
case so
that's why i enjoyed the text so much
and actually could we could you maybe
explain that that line of argument to
like like describe what matt just called
the like egalitarian or democratic
way in which individual rights would be
insured in like i guess
the communist uh i don't know if it's at
the point of communism or at the point
of socialism i'm not
but i'll try to do that and also by
returning to your question
and the issue about the withering way of
the state
uh as i try to answer this question well
the first thing to note is that there
were two
kind of argumentative devices used to
make the
argument uh or you know for the
conclusion that not only
will there be a place for law justice
and rights in this post-capitalist
society
but there's a functional reason for that
why that would be important
and then there's a normative reason why
that would be good right
and not simply you know play a
functional role
so the functional uh the functional
argument uh
is is that for mars if we turn to
capital
and the grinders he subscribes to the
view that every form of production has
to have
its own legal relations right so this
could be a purely
if you want an orthodox view right that
you can't have um
you can't have a base without a
superstructure i'm being very
vulgar and cruel crude here to use
familiar you know terminology
but if let's think that through for just
a moment
what he's trying to say is that in order
for us to have a mode of production
which for him
is expansive it captures the way that we
produce as human beings how we
communicate with each other
right and that for him says a whole lot
about the society in which we are living
or the you know social arrangements
under which we produce
including the standard of justice that
will prevail
right that will inform our actions you
see so the functional argument is that
law
or a system of right has a stabilizing
function it ensures
that the mode of production can sustain
itself
now that has happened you know in even
in pre-state societies to some extent
and sometimes this is inconsistent but
in angles
it then talks about you know so-called
primitive communism
or you know tribal societies they do
have you know
a system of rules and now you know
living in the colonial
settler colonial context if we can put
it in those terms
legal scholars have come to grips with
the fact that there were such things as
indigenous legal orders
right now uh
functionally it's important to have a
system of rules in order to ensure that
people can go about their business
regardless of which society the business
mate may be different
but people need to go about their
business so the functional argument and
and i try to find evidence for that in
in capital is that
law uh it for marx is indispensable for
functional purposes in order for a mode
of production
to sustain itself to consolidate itself
and to be
distinguished for mere chance and
arbitrariness as he puts it in capital
and he says that this is indispensable
in all modes of production so what
follows what follows is if mark is to be
consistent that means that
to the extent that communism or there
will be such a thing as a communist
modern production
it will also have to have a system of
justice that will
help coordinate affairs between
individuals the content of that system
will obviously
reflect the change needs of individuals
how they produce and reproduce the
materiality
but it cannot at least for the
argument's coherence
it cannot either wither away or
disappear and if it does then something
else has to take its place
that will simulate the same functional
role you see
so that's a purely functional argument
that isn't particularly interesting
but that's framed you know strictly
speaking uh
from uh nature of marx's arguments where
he says that every form of production
has to create its own legal relation so
i say
what does that mean for a
post-capitalist mode of production
um secondly the normative dimension
right
and for the normative dimension i had to
be a bit more creative obviously i can't
simply
you know emphasize this or that passage
and the argument there
is that there is a reason why there
needs to be a system of right
in this post-capital society and that
reason has to do with marx's commitment
to the free development of individuals
and how we are able to reconcile
the free development of each with the
free development of all
and this has to some extent i've been
told you know parallels with khan's
legal theory but there is one important
difference which is going to bring me to
the question of the state
okay in cons in con's doctrine of right
which is now receiving more and more
attention because
the new accounting hegemony some put it
in political
theory political philosophy the only way
that we can mediate between the the
freedom of each and the freedom of allah
makes clear
is through coercive law right and that
law has to be objective it's not the
moral law
it's sort of this is khan's legal and
political theory
which emphasizes coercion and
enforcement you see
so then the natural question would be
what ways is is uh
marx different from khan well this is
where the question of the state emerges
what
i do in the book and i think this is
really important i distinguish between
state and law
right which is not the case in mo for
most thinkers in the history of
political thought and this is one
area of disagreement i have with another
interpreter
commentary a great scholar for whom i
have a lot of respect and have
talked about these things with him alan
wood
right who's written on all you know the
important uh german classical german
idealists right
from khan to fifth and ultimately marx
though he wasn't an idealist arguably
and
what he says in his famous article
about marx and justice is that he grants
the possibility good that there will be
post-capitalist standards of right
and that is hard to deny when we read
the critique of the gotham program
but ultimately that there will be no
such standards or such standards won't
be
referenced because the only reason why
such standards would
be referenced is because there would
have to be a state that would enforce
the right you see so as far as const is
concerned we know that there will be
such a state now what happens
in the marxian framework so what i did
is i i tried to disentangle state and
law
just like i mentioned earlier that there
are such things as indigenous legal
orders
there weren't states as such there were
collective organization
forms of organization that enable people
to go about their daily lives
subject to a common set of rules and
carl pelani is a great transformation in
other works
he refers to you know economic
transactions if you will
as being embedded and certain normative
obligations
and understandings that people have
toward one another in a given society
right now what i try to do is to show
from marx's really early work
i would say the critique of hegel's
doctrine of the state his notes on the
philosophy of right
there is this view that the state what
hegel calls the state is superimposed
upon
individuals and societies another
version of that argument
occurs in the on the jewish question and
most people
miss out the fact that marx actually
cites rousseau
in on the jewish question he cites
russo's uh
legislator or law giver right as
exemplifying
the prototypical if you are the
quintessential form of alienation
uh because as russo puts it in social
contract we have to figure out a way
right that we would give
uh people alien powers powers that they
wouldn't otherwise have
now marx uh you know cites rousseau to
show that what resort was really getting
at
you know with marx's strategic purpose
in mind is he's
he's basically discussing uh the modern
form of alienation where by human beings
and remember he was influenced marcus
influenced by foreign here
project their powers their social powers
onto an alien entity
that then dominates them that alien
entity initially
is of course god in the foreign sense
but then for marx because he wants to
move beyond for iraq and his critique
it becomes the liberal state itself or
the modern state itself
that claims that citizens are free and
equal whereas in the sphere of civil
society
and he actually cites you know the
habitian
teaching a war of all against all so we
are divided selves
in on the jewish question and what i've
realized is that when you read his uh
notes on eagle's
uh doctrine of the state the philosophy
of right you read on the jewish
questions those early writings
you read on the holy family uh
collaborative work with ingles you begin
to see
that he has a specific point in mind
with respect to the state and which
aspect
of which specific aspect of the state
will have to wither away
although he doesn't use that language by
the way so i'll get into that shortly
and that has to do with this external
alienating dimension of the state that
is superimposed upon
individuals and my argument in the book
is that this view continues
up until at the very least not only his
discussion with bakunin
right the critical exchange of bakunin
the anarchist but also the critique of
the gotha program where he says that the
real function isn't to
call a liberal state or a free state he
makes fun of that what is the free state
he says
the chief goal should be to
see to it that the state instead of
being something that's super imposed
upon society is entirely subordinate to
it
in other words it's similar to what he
says about the jewish question that
instead of projecting our social powers
onto this alien entity we have to take
those powers back
right so that the state doesn't stand in
opposition to us as individuals and as
members of society
but that we are in charge of the state
rather than the state being in charge of
us
and that goes to what he says in in the
um
in the uh uh notes on hegel's philosophy
right you know when he says that
democracy
is the solved riddle of all
constitutions why because the people
you know the demos is supposed to
constitute
its law or its laws you see whereas he
takes
issue with hegel that ultimately no
constitutional monarchy
and can somehow represent the will the
interest of the people
so that in the democracy he says in that
early work
form and content are not at loggerheads
you know they're actually reconciled
so what i want to do is basically say
that in the critique of the good program
and in his exchange with bakunian the
critical exchange of bakunin
that's what will wither away
quote-unquote the reason why i say
quote-unquote is because engels was the
one
who makes reference to the withering
away of the state and even he
qualifies it by saying it's not so much
withering away
it's more like it dies out and becomes
superfluous which is an important
distinction
and obviously engels didn't think that
you know what we would today call the
state's administrative functions
including you know uh the things that
you were mentioning
uh victor about the various complexities
in a modern society that necessitate
you know an administrative apparatus of
some kind
to help coordinate the affairs of
individuals service provision and so on
and so forth
so i don't think that either engels or
marx judging by what i've read anyway
thought that that would wither away what
they did didn't like
is this repressive organ that's
superimposed upon society
that comes to dominate individuals
instead of being a vehicle
as it should be in khan's thought for
example for their emancipation
uh and we get more evidence for that in
the uh
in his reflections on the paris commune
where he talks about you know the
commons legit
the legitimate functions of courts for
example or if not
courts than uh civil servants so i think
i think what happened you know is people
read these things
right and sort of ran with it assuming
that you know there will be no room
for a collective administrative organ
that will you know
help people go about their business and
that law
is intricately bound up with such a
repressive state and of course if we
read kant then that's exactly the view
that we will uh we will get and that's
what happens with i think alan wood's
interpretation is the reason why they
can't be
a post capitalist let's call it a
communist
conception of right is because they
would have to be a state now they can't
be a state
so a communist state would be a
contradiction in terms in that
sense right and so of course when you
start with a set of
assumptions which which reads marx
right from the beginning of his you know
of his intellectual career to the bitter
end
as being hostile to the idea of the
state
in every sense of the word then you're
going to arrive at that conclusion and i
think that's what happened in most
interpretations
but we also have to account for what
i've just raised you know his exchange
with bakunin
his reflections on the paris commune the
idea that the state's legitimate
functions
would be restored to the responsible
agents of society
but that its illegitimate functions
would be
um you know uh i forget the exact word
that he uses amputated
is what he says so that what that tells
us
is even there a short-lived you know
revolt if you will
citizens of paris and so on it's a
radical and
if they weren't both of them weren't you
know marxists right
that's also important to understand uh
for marx you know
he was constantly as well give us give
us a picture what the dictatorship of
the proletariat looks like
angle's first part says look to the
paris commune that's the dictatorship of
the protest so
for those of us who are worried about
you know the specter of totalitarianism
we have to look at what the paris
commune was all about it was really
decentralized for example
and it didn't seek to destroy the state
as such smash the state as such
it wanted to smash according to marx's
interpretation at least a charitable
interpretation
um it's illegitimate function those
would have to be amputated
whereas its legitimate functions right
would have to be restored and
we we you know we refer to legitimate
right
in the sense that this is something that
the citizens
would actually want to preserve right
would stand by with support
so i think we have to pay attention to
these things and to go against the grain
of an interpretation that has been so
you know sort of etched in our in our
brains and our minds as students of
political thought so i was especially
grateful to matt that he opens his
review by
uh my book by you know recounting his
own experience as a student
right because as educators i think we
have a duty
to give the best possible case for any
given thinker that we teach
we can't start with our you know
prejudiced assumptions about plato
or aristotle marx even heidegger let's
say
right or schmidt for example right we
have to try and present
the thinker as they understood
themselves or at least show all the
complexities
and let's let the students right and the
readers decide for themselves
which interpretation they find most
plausible and convincing
and i think you know if i accomplish
anything in this book is to at least get
us to think twice
you know about preaching the
interpretation of marx
as having only contempt for rights
as has been done you know historically
and if there is any accomplishment i
would want
it to be that accomplishment and then
this would be followed up with the
various political implications that it
may or may not have
for those who identify as being on the
left
on the radical left in particular
i have two follow-up questions uh one is
is that really um what is a more
theoretical question i should say and
then one gets more to the heart
of the controversy around your book uh
so the more theoretical question is
uh would you actually characterize the
let's call it materials conception of
right
that you develop in your book as being
sharply demarcated from a canteen
conception of right uh and the reason
that i make this argument is
if you take something like arthur
ripstein's interpretation of camp it
doesn't seem all that
different from what you're talking about
because ripstein's argument of course is
that
while yes there will be a coercive state
on a canteen conception of how
liberalism should operate
uh the reason this coercion of just is
justified is of course because
on the canteen conception any law that's
imposed upon
us is the law that we give to ourselves
uh in this kind of republican framework
um you know we deliberate we pass laws
and and of course you know gripson
points out that this is
very much uh in keeping with rousseau's
influence on can't uh
very similar to the influencer cell hat
on marks right and the second
question i had for you that is again
more to the heart of the issue is
uh in your book you talk about how a
communist state would be as you put it
a stamp uh with the influence
of what came before and i was wondering
if you could elaborate a little bit more
on what you mean by uh the influence of
what came before
uh in a potential communist future
well the first thing to note is i'll
start with your uh
comment about arthur rip's team it's
just so happens that i wrote an article
in the canadian
journal of laundry prudence which draws
upon the
legal theory of eugenie pasha karnas who
is sort of my
antagonist in the book because i have to
respond to him
again i have a lot of respect for
pashikanis but i think he made a tragic
error theoretical and ultimately
political which cost him his life
i'm not making a causal claim here
because you know i don't want to
exaggerate the
the power of legal and political theory
but the reason why it matters in this
context the reason why it matters in
this context is because the question of
legal theory legal philosophy
in the soviet union during that time was
a question of life and death and that's
actually how i
conclude that article the article is
called
estranged bedfellows why uh contemporary
formalists
legal formalists should be worried about
pashukanyas
and i show a strange convergence between
uh pashukanas on the one hand and
contemporary
neocontin perhaps it's fair to call them
kantian
formulas because there's no neo as far
as i'm concerned they think that kant
has all the resources necessary
for a full-blown legal theory and they
may be right about that but that doesn't
mean that that's particularly appealing
or successful legal theory
so what i do is i begin by showing what
the legal uh formalists have in common
with pleasure kindness and it turns out
that both of them place an emphasis
on private law and commodity exchange
and they want that to be separate from
conceptually separate from
autonomous from and distinct from public
law and ripsteam
does an excellent job in my view in his
book uh private wrongs
uh showing why that's really important
he does it really clearly
but i take issue with his interpretation
and show that politically in any case if
you're committed to distributive justice
as
rosians are uh the the view
that the continue that the continues put
forward
mike ripstein is actually
riddled with uh all these contradictions
and tensions between private right and
public right public law and
uh private law so pasha khan is for
sees the distinguishing feature of law
is not
regulatory right law you know if we're
to define
law typically you know if you turn to a
legal theorist they'll say it has
something to do
with this comprehensive set of
authoritative rules right
that help coordinate society well for
prashar khan is when
that's his brilliance too that he was
able to pinpoint it so that doesn't
explain
how law is different from the army for
example right
there are also authoritative rules in
fact all the more oppressive
or the church right where there's
hierarchy and the rules as well
and so what ends up happening is legal
theorists who subscribe to this view
actually miss out on what makes law
distinctive and for look for pasha
kindness
he follows in his book the general
theory of law of marxism
as saying that conflict is the starting
point in law
an opposition of interest but not of any
interest right because
we could say there could be an
opposition of interest between citizens
no
that's not what bush has in mind it's
the opposition of private interest
between bearers of rights and commodity
owners in particular in
other words owners of private property
and this
this line in paschal kindness is is very
close
it's close affinity with the foremost
for them
private right private law law of torts
property and so on i would even say
contract if we are to be consistent
is the is the real distinguishing
feature of law it's the real law
and everything else follows from that
because it it rests on the idea of the
legal or juridical person but the reason
why i end up criticizing arthur
epstein's private wrongs in the end
is by saying that by absolutizing
private right
the idea you know that freedom
and all other forms of law is to be
sought in this idea of
being an owner of private property
engaging in commodity exchange
actually prevents right the on the best
interpretation the rolls in ideal of
distributive justice
that ripstin and others like him assign
to public law
and to public right in other words you
can't do anything about um
private right you can't change it but in
public law
it's all about redistribution it's all
about distributive justice
however private law private right is all
about corrective justice
so what i end up showing actually citing
marx's grunderson
marx has a very witty passage in the
grinder so where he says look let's take
one of the most progressive economists
of the time and that was john stuart
mill
a classical liberal who became something
of a social so more inclined
you know to profit sharing and
cooperatives closer to the end of his
life
mill says that we can't do anything
about production it's like a law of
nature the way the production is
organized
but in distribution right we have zero
you know we have a hundred
let's say 360 degrees of of
arbitrariness we can do what we want
so i assigned the same view to arthur
ribson in the sense of
as far as private rights is concerned we
can't change the structure of property
relations those have to be fixed
because otherwise would undermine what
private rights stands for
you know the autonomy of entering into
contracts as people wish
except that certain parties within
private right end up dominating others
who don't own
a private property of a certain kind but
then as soon as we get to public right
to public law you know we arrive at the
royals in state i don't find that
convincing in the least frankly
and i think it it actually leads to a
conflict
between the two goals on the one hand in
private rights
the goal is to allow for you know uh
unlimited unfettered commodity exchange
and then
in public right the state right is
it's tasked with this role of making
everyone a full citizen
right how to reconcile that it's not
made clear in
in ripstein's private wrongs and it and
it tends to emphasize in my view the
worst features of both
spheres of right in private right what's
emphasizes the libertarian
extreme you know you can't intervene in
private right otherwise you dissolve
private right into public right
in the public right on the country what
you do is you absolutize the role of the
state
in other words the state can do as it
pleases if it wishes to
realize distributive justice that too is
a problem if you're a libertarian for
example
or if you're worried that private right
would be dissolved so
conceptually you can have these rigid
distinctions but in practice we know
you know there's a revolving door
between the two spheres of right
i would argue and for this reason i
think that if we're really interested
about reconciling and maintaining you
know a difference between private right
and public right
we actually have to talk about the
structure of property relations we can't
say
as rip steam and others do ripstin is
influenced by the way
by another very important legal theorist
namely ernst ernest weinreim
who you know is famous for putting forth
this view of corrective justice
so in order for us to really reconcile
public and private right
what we have to do is to pay attention
to the structure of property relations
and how they either undermine
or support both private right and public
right
so if it turns out right that and this
is actually
an insight i got from alan wood i shared
my article with alan wood in advance
and he says well wait a second you could
you could be a continent pardon me
and support you know uh a vision
that is hostile opposed to exploitation
right because what ends up happening
in the capital society is that the
rights of workers they're the as
suitors as being their own masters right
as being their own legislators is
undermined because
they're subject not only to the will of
another individual
the capitalist right for whom they work
but also of an impersonal
system that instead of being a vehicle
for their freedom actually enslaves them
as wage slaves
right so so what is to bring it back to
your own question man
so what is what ways is my view
different from the content view one
is that is that or is that a uh fair
way of uh yeah the way i want my
favorite is this like
granted i absolutely agree that marx
would be far more critical of private
property and property relations than
camp would be i don't think there's any
dispute about that
um but i think that rip steam's point in
force and freedom
is that ultimately kant is committed to
a conception
of social freedom because she says that
any kind of law
that is imposed from above needs to
emerge from the bottom up
right it needs to be a law that we give
to ourselves and suppose what i'm saying
you know really down to earth is
how would democratic procedures be
different on a market
is just perception conception uh then on
this canteen conception
all right can i can i just add to that
yeah yeah like i guess another way like
i maybe had a similar question too which
because you were talking about like the
problem with
the st is that you're letting the state
regulate the public or like all the
public right like and you see that as a
problem and i guess like i initially
thought and maybe it's related to what
matt said it's like
but if the state is legitimate in the
sense that that like the laws come from
below
that are that are regulating the public
right then why would that be
necessarily like you know prime if ratio
bad
okay so in principle maybe you know on a
charitable interpretation
it's bottom up but it's at least as far
and i'm teaching
khan's doctrine of right in my modern
political theory course because i think
it's very important
in practice or at least you know it's
practical implications is we have to
understand
that kant uh does have a fairly generous
uh
uh you know you could say uh provisions
for welfare of the poor
but let's not forget and i could be
wrong maybe
jacob weiner or ernie weiner will
correct me after this podcast if they if
they tune
into it that notwithstanding these
generous provisions
of because he realizes that the vast
majority of individuals are actually
heteronomous they're dependent upon
others
but notice he then uses that as an
argument for excluding the vast majority
of individuals from political
participation and that's something
that of course uh you know thinkers
conscience like ripstein
and uh and why not emphasis but that's a
fact if we
if we take him seriously he basically
says it's because they're heteronos
it's because you know the working poor
and wage laborers or day laborers
are poor that they are dependent in
other words they could be manipulated
their will may be manipulated
and including by the wealthy which is
why we should exclude them
from this process that doesn't mean that
we shouldn't you know
help them as far as social welfare is
concerned to be full citizens but you
can't be
without due respect you can't be a full
citizen if you're excluded from the
process of participating
in making your own laws so that speaks
to an inconsistency
in cons legal and political authority uh
thought
granted uh so one important difference
is uh
this is why you know i think private
property is important
it's not so in marx it's not a basis for
political participation
uh and representation right for marx
what ends up happening is it's an
important feature to
political uh participation full
citizenship although ultimately marx
isn't
you know bound up with citizenship
because citizenship is bound up
strictly speaking with the territorial
uh boundaries of the
of the nation state and he was looking
forward to internationalism right there
will still be nations
but the relationship between nations
would be very different and that's also
not a world state or a
federation of states in this continent
framework the latter being
a federation of republics so uh
one thing to note is that account is not
entirely clear of including everyone
in the process of making their own laws
to which they are subject
in principle as alan wood said correctly
to me he is committed to the first
and innate right of being your own
you know being your own master and i
think that's something that's really
important and in some sense
yes there is an important convergence
between marx and kant here
except marx i would argue is more
consistent with that than his continents
in his social and political thought and
this has also
given rise i think to another dimension
in marxian scholarship with the work of
william claire roberts with uh
bruno leopold with uh camila
vergara right this kind of an attempt to
republicanize marx and i think in some
sense it's good
but in some sense it has its limitations
and for me the biggest limitation
is that in the republican tradition and
can't i include continuous
tradition and resolve in order for us to
talk about domination
right and think about the new republican
tradition in particular domination has
to be bound up with a particular
empirical person who exercises the
arbitrary will over other individuals
now marx
right i think i give credit to william
claire roberts where he's being attuned
to this point he still wants to situate
marx
along with gravity in the you know
radical republican tradition
i say to a point that works but then
there's the impersonal system
the capitalist market system that is not
personal that you can't be
you know can't point your finger and
hold a particular
individual to account that also makes
marxian
social political thought distinctive
you'll remember i know you've written a
lot about
uh you know the work of jordan peterson
from you know
so let me just bring up the only thing
that i found relatively intellectually
stimulating
with his debate in his debate with
slavoy
it wasn't the point that he hadn't read
the communist manifesto for 30 years i
mean you can't blame people
for not reading and first of all the
communist manifesto for the record was a
political pamphlet it's not a yeah
you know the classic work i mean you say
you can't blame him i would uh
then you should be pretty knowledgeable
of that tradition right i think
as an academic that's a fairly minimal
expectation
yeah it's like fair enough you're the
authority on this stuff
it does bring me it does bring me to my
my critical point
there was a point in which peterson
during this debate was referring to
marx's alleged view that capitalists are
evil
notice this moralizing which marx
actually never entertained he did talk
about capitalism the system itself
as being defined by you know blood
dripping vampire sucking and so on all
the rest of it but notice these are all
impersonal
right kind of characterizations and
that's important because remarks you
know as i tell my
my students using various you know
outdated pop cultural
and problematic references it's the game
and not the player
right and so there's a reason for that
because and this is why it's
important to distinguish him from the
republican neo-republican tradition is
you can't blame a specific empirical
individual
and say that the domination right stems
from that
because the domination is also by a
class
right that owns the means of production
and uses that politically
to their advantage indirectly rawls
recognize that as a problem in justice's
fairness restatement
which is why in my book i try to show
that as far as the liberal tradition is
concerned in the
20th century raul stands as one of the
only thinkers to have really taken his
marxist critique seriously and tried to
respond to it
yeah right so rose recognizes that
and then you know the only in my view
liberal political theory theories that
really have made an effort to deal with
this problem
are those like you know iris mary and
young talking about structural forms of
oppression
and injustice but the problem is they
are not as a tune as marx was to
extend to which capitalism as a system
rather than simply you know an
association of individuals
uh generates those not only inequalities
but forms of domination
so i guess one important difference
would be that
that the republican tradition in its
contemporary forms
has to track and this comes from roman
law right it comes from that tradition
has to track it back to a specific
empirical person and in fact in my
article
in the canadian journal of laundry
response where i take issue with rip
steam
i argue that he's great at showing how
dominant you know personal domination or
direct domination
rip sin is great and the republican
tradition does an excellent job but what
happens when the
nature of the domination is impersonal
well then according to
the formalists the county informs no
private wrong exists
except we know for those of us anyway
who think that workers are exploited and
taken advantage of
and this that by the way doesn't have to
rest on a labor to your value people
just say
oh you subscribe to labor through your
value that's that's why we don't have to
take critique seriously
it's not so simple right it's that
you end up entering into a contract
where everyone is free and equal and
somehow
one party to that contract ends up
enriching itself and the other
either finds itself poorer right or
subject to greater heteronomy and it's
up to
the continents to explain why that is
whereby a contract that
begins among equals ends with unequals
right
uh so i think i think this the issue is
figuring out
if you're a republican right in this
either schenerian or a titian
variant or i would say you know my my
colleagues
bruno leopold and uh
chambers is uh uh oh sorry
william claire roberts is is that
the challenge is to figure out how we
can hold people accountable
and if not people assist them
accountable to generating various forms
of domination
within the confines of a republican
uh thought that is still tethered to
roman law
you know parameters right
so that would be my challenge in terms
of the second point if i may
about uh how a communist society would
nonetheless inherit
right developments unleashed by a
capitalist society
that comes directly from the critique of
the go to program except
of course marx is talking about the
so-called first stage of communism he
says very clearly
what we have to deal with is communist
society not as his
as it has developed on its own
foundation but just as it emerges
right from the womb of the capitalist
society in that sense is
morally intellectually technologically
if you will economically
right um uh colored if you will
with uh the um the norms and the
practices
that it inherits from such a society so
in other words what i wanted to do is to
show the dialectical
nature of marx's argument right for the
generation
of kind of a communist conception of
right first the first stage she even
refers to
us as really making good on bourgeois
right
because no one you know so you have
people being
remunerated according to their labor
power right
and that leads to a whole host of
inequalities
so he says we still we still have this
it's a it's an advance this first stage
because now we don't have people being
exploited
and people get the workers if you will
uh get renumerated based on the work
that they
produce right or that they do but that
will lead to various inequalities and
right instead of being equal as a
standard would have to be unequal
because human beings he says are unequal
and different
by the way this may this may be a
provocation matt
but uh marx was not an egalitarian in
the strict sense of the word
what do i mean by that we can understand
egalitarianism in many different
respects
we could understand the idea of a moral
equality
right that's the idea that human beings
are essentially
born free and equal in that sense then
there's political equality that as far
as political participation goes there
should be no differences
or constraints unlike let's say in john
stewart mill who thought that
some people should be given more votes
than others because
right i'm just just as an example i'm
not trying to criticize him here
there are other reasons to criticize him
perhaps sure
um uh and then there is another another
variant
with which we were most familiar the
distributive dimension the economic
legality and he was not an economic
egalitarian
and which is why i always know when i
teach marx particularly the particular
program i ask my students
two questions one can we equalize
people's needs
and the second question can we equalize
their abilities
theoretically maybe but not in practice
and that stands for marx's you know
complex
view of the individual right the human
beings
that there's something concrete about
human beings that can never be subject
to one
homogenous egalitarian standard because
if we would do that
we would end up treating individuals
arbitrarily so he does
it granted and this is where jerry cohen
comes in he does say
that in the first stage right the fact
that some workers are going to be more
productive obviously
and they're going to get more uh you
know
rewards as a consequence of their
productivity there's a problem there
because
we treat genetic endowments rawls
obviously
also grants that as if they're natural
privileges but what marx is getting at
isn't like egalitarianism in my view
it's that you know as he says the needs
of the stomach
right and once productive output should
not be you know
fused because we all have the needs of
the stomach
right obviously some more than others
and the same thing goes with health care
right but he doesn't want you know one's
productivity and
endowments to be a basis for you know
preventing others from realizing their
capacities
right so he wants to sort of separate
those two but he realizes you know i
think as a pragmatist
uh someone who's pragmatic i should say
that uh within the first stage
right of communism we're still very much
you know living with the legacy of the
past
and we still believe in the idea that we
should be paid according to our labor
except in this stage we would actually
follow through with that
with that principle we won't have one
class
exploiting another because there will be
only one class
right in this case it's the the class of
how everyone becomes a worker but that
he too
finds that defective because everything
else about the individual worker is
ignored the concrete is ignored
and we're putting everyone under the
same standard but the application
of the same standard for different
individuals will result in
inequalities and quite detrimental
inequalities
and so that's why he hopes that with the
development of the productive forces
right there will be something like
relative abundance with respect to food
sheltering clothing so that we won't you
know be so fixated
on who gets what how much right
instead we'll figure out a way in which
people will be able to contribute
according to
their abilities and consume according to
their needs and as
alan wood says correctly that is not an
egalitarian principle in the sense of
economic egalitarian
principle because we can't equalize
people's needs
or their ability and if we do that we
would actually do an injustice
to them as far as marx is concerned
that's interesting i completely agree
with you that i don't think marx is an
economic egalitarian in the strict sense
of the word
but i think he's an egalitarian in the
more fundamental sense and he shares
this with the liberal tradition
uh in the sense that he believes in the
moral equality
of all individuals right which is
something that's very distinct from what
my brother called the reactionary
tradition
uh you know embodied in somebody like
nietzsche who says that they know some
people are worth more than others
fundamentally right uh you can also like
situate uh aristotle and a few others in
that kind of situation yeah okay
um can i just like push on one thing so
i just want
some wondering earlier you said
something about like the marxist
conception of law and you
you know you you paralleled it with some
in some indigenous concepts of law right
where there's like rules that are
that are sort of collectively um
collectively determined or collectively
reached and i guess
my question about that is you know like
with that that it sounds to me to imply
like positive rights in the sense that
it sounds like with that kind of
structure
you require people to actually be
participating actively in some ways to
make those laws like they have to be a
participant
in the law making and they and in other
words they have certain responsibilities
right like if you think about
i mean not that i'm an expert on
indigenous law by any means but there's
like an expectation that people in those
communities will be like active
participants in order to maintain the
traditions right
and i guess that's something that like
coming from maybe my own
more liberal like perspective like i
really like negative liberties like i
really like to not be bothered like
leave me alone i don't want to be forced
to
i'm lazy i don't want to go to like
commune meetings and like
decide how much we're going to be doing
and how we're going to be maintaining
like the the social order and like you
know if i don't want to participate in
those things like i'd rather just have
some alienated structure take care of
that in the background for me right so
so i'm just wondering you know from my
my sort of like like dirty lib
provocation like i wonder if you you had
some thoughts about that like you know
because if that's the conception of law
that's like a marxist law like i'm not
interested you know
all right without the [ __ ] alone let me
uh preface that with an anti-communist
joke uh
by telling it to you to your example
that after the revolution you will learn
to attend
at the love attending commune meetings
so that won't be right
but to be on a serious note uh well i
use that example actually that quickly
that reminds me of that of that old
saying you know freedom is an endless
meeting
right apparently apparently
uh so so so two things the first is that
you know i use the example of indigenous
legal words to show that it would be
possible to
come up with a conception of law uh or
of right
that is on the one hand pre-state or not
necessarily bound up with the state
that's the first thing
and also that it's not necessarily bound
up with private property because we know
in most indigenous communities not all
private property doesn't have the same
significance that it has you know
in our society and its frameworks right
so to be at least open to the
possibility that
not all forms of law are necessarily
bound up with the state
and with private property and i'm
actually interested in this on the
research kind of level of note as well
to learn from you know indigenous legal
orders to show the extent to which you
know there's detention with the marxist
tradition because marxism
is thoroughly modern not you know and
that comes with a whole series of
implications and consequences
but also to criticize you know the the
kantian tradition and to pasha kunis
right basically
in my view in the same article in the
canadian journal of long jurisprudence
cannot make sense of any uh
conception of law that isn't bourgeois i
mean that's a problem
because what it does it basically says
that we're bound up with bourgeois law
and it's the end of history and for our
marxists that's really bizarre
and then what do you offer instead
technical regulations so we're trying to
figure out
you know when we make up rules what's
the most efficient way of moving from
point a to point b
without asking about what human costs
that may have
we just take it for granted that will
agree on that well i haven't been
persuaded by that
but mar by the way possible is the most
systematic legal theorist in the marxist
tradition
right which is why we must take him
seriously but let me respond by
also kind of really bringing it back to
a question
about the inheritance of various aspects
of capital society that i didn't fully
articulate in my previous response
in the grinder sub which was one of my
four more favorite works
marx is really hegelian there he talks
about this kind of
a three-stage process without the
teleological thing in mind
i think there it's sort of conceptual
right that there's certain features
in pre-capitalist societies that
distinguish them from capitalist
societies
including he i think he would agree uh
indigenous
uh forms of association right what ends
up happening in the pre-modern world
in marx's view is that there isn't a
separate sphere
carved out for the individual right the
private sphere
where they could as i've said previously
assert themselves
as individuals we know from constant
right that the liberty of the ancients
prevented that sphere from developing we
know that in plato's republic that's
something that
we want to banish right hegel reminds us
about him
and that's an injustice thing that i'm
attached to here that's the private
sphere you think
well i mean i think that's a big part of
it right which is why i think private
property became so important because it
was
an attempt to try and prevent the state
from swallowing up
that sphere and the individual's fear of
you know for self-assertion so we
shouldn't simply
you know poo poo on that and and um
marx doesn't you know even in the you
know economic and philosophical
manuscripts of 1844.
he he argues that one of the defects of
what he calls crude communism barracks
communism
is that it hasn't fully appreciated
the contribution of private property to
not only the flowering of human needs
but also to the creation of civilization
though it includes alienation and so
what he sees communism as and that
is the is the retrieval again like in
the jewish question
right and the reappropriation
right of nature and of objects human
desires for the human being so whatever
concept of in my book i basically say
that marx still has room
for concept of individual property the
personal property
individual right which is basically
uh goes against the grain of most
interpretations because everyone reads
in the communist manifesto if communism
can be summed up in one line
abolition of private property but then
it follows with with a very
clear designation that individual
property would not be abolished
right no one reads that past that point
you have to understand it's a polemical
article
and that's what led to the view that
they'll simply there's simply common
ownership of the means of production and
no individual property at all
so in the grinder he talks about a
pre-modern society the first stage
where the individual is kind of fully
submerged in the community it doesn't
exist
as an individual as such and maybe you
could argue that that's the case in
indigenous legal orders but that's the
thing i'm scared of i guess
yeah yeah but again first of all that
that is an anthropological question as
well we actually need to know
what you know we can't just assume that
that's the case and i think marx is
assuming in some sense
and he's not simply talking he's talking
about all forms of association
where the individual submerged in the
community and he calls that
as you know in various places system of
direct domination
right um i'm glad you said that cause i
was going to bring up that as being also
a form of domination potentially so i'm
glad you brought that up so this is in
the grundus and i actually have a
i don't have my book on hand but i'll be
able to to find it for you
and then the second stage is a stage
where there's a system of formal freedom
in place
right and what he calls objective
dependence and he's referring to a
capitalist form of association where on
the one hand we're formally free
but we also are unfree in the sense that
we're dependent on an
impersonal system that then comes to
dominate us right
but the virtue of such a system is that
it it really you know generates our
needs it shows our creative capacities
for the first time
it carves out a separate space for the
individual which is a real development
not simply a deceptive one we are indeed
alienated but it's through that
alienation that we come to realize
that we have capacities as individuals
and we're not merely products of the
community
and so on the third the third stage is
he puts it he's talking about communism
he refers to free individuality right
and what what's interesting is he says
that the second condition the second
stage creates the conditions for the
third which is why the development of
exchange relations
is so important right for marx even
though it also produces
right because of the capitalist
structure of production system of
production
also produces alienation inequalities of
various class inequalities in particular
and forms of domination but notice he
says the third
stage stage depends upon the development
proliferation of the second
so which leads me back to the point
about inheriting the developments of
capitalism
those are not simply technical or
technological they're also
ethical you know in a sense uh in
capital to go back to the equality part
he criticizes aristotle he draws on
aristotle's discussion of use and
exchange
but then he says the reason why
aristotle couldn't make sense of a
homogeneous conception of value kind of
how can we exchange houses and beds to
qualitatively different
commodities well the reason why you
can't make sense of that according to
once you could be wrong
is because aristotle lived in society
which was defined and characterized by
slavery including inequalities in the
quality
of of labor right so labor could not
have been
the unifying standard of value and he
says the only
context in which that is possible is
when equality becomes a popular
prejudice
so it goes back to the point about
entering into contract
contracts can only be entered into by
equals not
between slaves and masters slaves cannot
enter into contracts neither can serves
because they're conceived as as articles
of property and that first stage
at first stage uh here if it's part of
this view that the individual submerged
in the community
or simply seen as an article of
production or
property that belongs to someone else so
the great
legacy if you will of capitalism or the
strivings towards capitalism is that
it develops the concept of the
individual as a legal person
and we talked about that showing itself
most clearly in roman law
the idea of the you know juridical
persona but obviously that too was
contradicted by the reality of slavery
and other forms of inequality right
because it wasn't extended that status
was not extended to everyone and you
know thinkers like charles mills
right have written a lot about the
political economy of personnel
and how just being a human being is not
a precondition
for being a person corporations can be
persons but not all human beings have
been
recognized as a person which is
important to understand but without that
we can't have a communist conception of
the social individual
and so i've always found it absurd
frankly
that people would say you'd have the
withering away of the legal person in
the communist society
well if that's the case then we have to
revert back to a situation where the
individual is entirely
submerged in the community so what marx
this is why you know dialectics is
important and hegel is important here
what he wants to do is he wants to
uh sublate right the the
the contradictions and the tensions
right
in the capital society by
kind of reconstituting the legal person
on a new and higher basis
because if that's not the case then you
have to you know we have to go back in
time
you know and and i guess we're left with
the individual submerged into the
community
and marx doesn't think that's
emancipation it's we haven't even
reached political emancipation
in that such a context it's funny though
that some modern leftists seem to seem
to
want that hold that view some uh a
little bit oh yeah
well that's what i mean i mean which is
why i think we get the pushback
when you try to argue that there's room
for
both a reconstitution of the juridical
person of rights and even of a legal
system
beyond capitalism you get this criticism
that okay you know
liberalism is the end of history i i've
never argued that i don't argue that in
the book
yeah of course but it's easy to arrive
at such a conclusion
because again it's it's a very
manichaean view right you just see
either liberalism or neuroliberalism and
maybe you do i don't know victor but i
don't yeah no no i mean you're you're
bringing up
like uh convincing interesting points
here but so that that can be found
easily in the grunderson and remember in
the particular goto program he says
right can never be higher than the
economic
structure of society and its cultural
development condition nearby
so that means there can be higher
standards of ride in my view
which you know is different from alan
wood's view is that there will be such a
higher
conception of writing in marx's view but
if it's going to be higher we have to
have a basis by which we can say
it's higher right we can't say it's more
just we i mean we could but
for marx justice is historically
situated and that trans-historical basis
in my view is
human freedom and how much it's
developed you see so if we say that in
the first stage
human freedom according to marx has
developed only to a tiny
degree because we haven't fully
separated ourselves from nature in his
view
and we're submerged in the community
under capitalism the second stage we are
you know developing our needs
unlike ever before which is why marx
thinks the bourgeoisie is a
revolutionary class
right it tears us under all forms of
fixed hierarchy
all that is solid melts into air and
then you have the third stage and again
this is not teleological it's conceptual
right to understand what a fully free
association would entail
presupposes that we've achieved
political emancipation the granting of
rights
and we supersede it right instead of
trying to negate it
right and that for first understand that
that's why you know
i i i turn to abdelhoven because there's
just no other way of understanding that
process and how it
would unfold and also for those
interested you know there is of course
the
18 premier louis bonaparte where he
talks about the poach of the future
he says you know we should let the dead
bury the dead but the problem with that
is
there's always time for mourning there
should be time for mourning
and we can't start our society this
emancipatory society from scratch
we he he says even there the weight of
all dead generations weighs like a
nightmare
on the minds of the living so how would
that you know that's
that's part of what it means to be human
right to live with the nightmares of the
past including the
capitalist nightmares with which we are
still living yeah
um okay yeah i mean i guess i'm still
wondering you know i i know i i know i'm
cognizant of the time here and stuff
like that but i
am still a little bit curious about you
know because it like
how did maybe this is a very like
simpleton like lib question but you know
what's the
like the is is the thought that like
once we reach this higher level of human
emancipation
then i guess what seems to me like that
like a tension between i suppose um
um democracy and
liberalism or something like that or
like rights
right like is that just going to somehow
be a co like no longer a problem because
like i guess if
if if laws and rights are kind of
somehow radically democratized which is
kind of what it sounds like you're
saying like this collective control
then i guess there's always like the
worry from uh
from my perspective that like that that
you know the reason we have laws is
right it's like
it's to temper uh democratic when when
democracy potentially goes wrong and
that's probably like a very you know
like lib lib
pessimistic perspective but i guess so
so would you say then that this
depends on the human being transformed
somehow right because like
right now like with the human beings
that exist in our society
that risk seems really real and with
what's happening right now like
democracy going awry and
but whereas like in this it's like it
depends on some view that the human
being is just transformed such that
we're not worried about that anymore is
that a mischaracterization
i think it's part of the
mischaracterization but it has roots in
the way that many marxists have gone
about trying to
deal with this very complicated subject
so basically is a good example
because in place of the legal form he
wants to have technical regulation and
he assumes unity
of social purpose so that just assumes
away the problem and i'm not convinced
by that and i think
right it's very dangerous and here
liberals may be right and
when they say that it assumes a
post-political society
in my book what i end up saying is if we
look very carefully and read
what marx writes in his famous 1859
preface
you know to the contribution the
critique of political economy talks
about
you know the end of prehistory but the
beginning of conscious human history not
the end of history this is an absurd
view
i think that was fostered upon marx and
marxism and also upon hegel
by who
who in my view never fully grasped even
the kojevian
interpretation of the struggle for
recognition but that's just my own view
i think
fukayama's current work is a lot more
sophisticated i was
interesting right yeah and more
historical in a sense than
than that very popular book which came
out
you know at a very distinct time right
which yeah which which is why it had
such attraction in my view
with respect to fukuyama but even there
the beginning of conscious human history
means now we don't have excuses now
we're not
the subject of alien powers and whims
now we have to take responsibility for
our actions and to determine our
destinies right
so that's the first evidence in my view
against this
idea of a post-political society another
argument is
in the capital right where he talks
about the realm of human freedom
blossoming
right he talks about the associated
producers rationally governing their
interchange with nature so that says
something about you know the future of
the environment too
that they're rational and irrational
ways of governing our interchange with
nature
and then he says in a manner worthy of
their human nature in other words we
can't produce any which way
under communism we have to produce in a
manner that is worthy of
our human nature as free beings and so
it's not possible to do that under
capitalism because the game tells us
that
the only way of getting ahead is if we
bring someone else down
right and that to bring it back to
peterson right
you know it's not about an evil
capitalist capitalists are also
eliminated in a sense
certainly not as much as workers uh in
that they have to compete
in this game right they have to take
advantage even if they don't want and if
they're going to be nice capitals
they're not going to survive for very
long
in the market right that's just an
objective fact if you will
so the point is just to interject there
i would say that actually
he takes a very reactionary pact
in these kind of respects because one of
the characteristics of conservative
particularly
uh right-wing conservative uh approaches
is sympathy
uh for alienated people who happen to
exist in positions of power right and a
lot of the examples that he brings up
uh throughout his work are precisely
about the fact that
well if you think about how hard lawyers
worked in order to get where they are
how hard it is to actually run a company
you should build sympathy for these
individuals imagine what they've
sacrificed and so on and so forth
and the emphasis is pretty telling right
and it is kind of
funny to think of what marx would say uh
worried to be writing about jordan
peterson right because i imagine
that his satire would be quite exquisite
uh to actually enjoy right sure sure and
that what i
would add though what i tried to mention
is the moralizing attitude
the reactionary moralizing the attitude
but marx you know moralizing was
anathema to marx
which is why perhaps you know he didn't
take it as seriously as he should have
that potentially would say manipulatory
role of talking about justice
is he lived in a victorian society if
someone would follow
on a banana appeal the first thing they
would say is an injustice has been done
to me
or it's an affront to my dignity and you
know there was a certain allergy towards
this kind of language because it was
used and abused not only by liberals but
by conservatives
as well right and an abstract appeal to
justice
and then you know in a situation where
there's vast inequality and domination
so he says for example in the critique
of the program
do not does the bourgeoisie not think
the present order is just
so what's the point of appealing to
justice in the abstract
because there is no way of adjudicating
whose conception of justice really is
just
in a capitalist society where you know
the law is organized in certain way
uh to you know further the interest of
one class over the other
um but the victor i think i think the
point is basically that it's not a
post-political society that's one thing
that we cannot that that
potential contradiction there would
still be like institutions
yeah yeah so the place of law in my view
is uh is uh as a mediating role to
ensure that the freedom of each
coheres with the freedom of all and the
absence of such an institution
even if you and i for example don't have
conflicting interests right
you're not exploiting me i'm not
exploiting you but you wanna you wanna
turn on your radio
at midnight because you're a lover of
music and i wanna go to sleep
we need to figure out a way that we
could work together so that you could
pursue your aim and i can pursue mine
you see it's this is a very simplistic
headphones
yeah get headphones or whatever right
this is just a simplistic example that
shows
how conflicts can emerge that are not
bound up with
you know class antagonisms right we live
in a society that's still defined by
those antagonists but
the problem with the pashukanas of the
world is that they assume that problem
away and i don't want to
and even angles if you're curious about
this he did anticipate the question of
what would happen
in the communist societies in his
speeches in albert albertfield which i
cite in the book
and here there he assumes i think is
rather optimistic
that the vast majority of conflicts
which emerge from you know
private property and you know thefts all
these other things
so private right by the way as opposed
to public right and bring it back to
our dear formalists uh
still there'll be disagreements but he
thinks they'll easily be resolved by
arbitrators so you see even there we
have evidence
that there will be some institutional
feature and you look they're sketching
out
a society that doesn't exist within the
framework of the existing society
so even angles who you know is you know
they attributed
with the famous point about the
withering away of the state
this is angle saying that they'll still
be conflicts except
they'll be solved by um arbitrators and
what does it mean to be an arbitrary
maybe you're not a professional like the
way the weber wanted it
you know professional lawyers and
separate associations
drawn from the middle class or hegel
civil servants universal class but
you know you need to have an impartial
conception of justice that will allow
you to adjudicate between competing
claims
however rare those claims may be and
angles allowed for
their possibilities there will be such
claims so you see even the classics
right to whom we impose and attribute
these simplistic you know
views anticipated this and you know
responded to it it's just that they
never
had a worked out theory of law and right
in the spirit of hegel
of uh of kant but that doesn't mean we
we shouldn't take them seriously you
know and and assume those questions away
angles didn't
in my v and marks didn't either and and
we have to take them at their best now
that they're worse
that's good no that's really interesting
yeah um
maybe yeah so and i guess just like kind
of jokingly you know so that means
there'll be institutions that means i
can still uh do my own thing and be a
free rider
well that's not good well you know every
society
every society has its own mechanisms
that it uses to get people on board
capitalist society has it right you know
let me give an example
you know think of the protestant ethic
in the spirit of capitalism when we go
to uh when we used to go to the pub or
a restaurant there is this informal
though nonetheless morally
mandatory tipping system which in some
sense you know doesn't actually
contribute to
the improvement of the condition of the
working class it makes them ever more
dependent
right yeah and yet somehow we feel
compelled to pay the tips because we
know that the workers aren't getting
paid very well
where does this come from so that's an
informal mechanism that's used by a
certain system
to get consumers to pay twice so instead
of getting
employers to pay better wages or to
legislate that
you know through the government right we
end up somehow
paying because we feel guilty to use
nietzsche against conscience well the
good the good ones of us pay
yeah but it's really it's rare the good
ones you know because again i'm not
going to borrow well it's funny i think
it's also our generation more though
you'd be surprised like i know a lot of
friends who are servers right and it's
like older people some
like are way more common to not tip and
it's natural
it's cultural as well like in you know
in the uk for example in japan
in japan it's interpreted as an affront
to one's dignity
to some extent right which also should
you know alert us
right there are different mechanisms
that are used to achieve
let's say uh social goals right sure
um and there's no reason why you know we
can't get you to
avoid free riding by ostracizing you for
example your ancient
ways and that's a rejoinder to your joke
okay good okay so
i know we're like running out of time
here so just briefly maybe like in the
last like a little bit we can
briefly talk about kind of like the
online landscape of leftists if you
don't mind like
just the reaction obviously matt you
wrote an article not too long ago
defending
some like the compatibility between
socialism and liberal rights and of
course the review of igor's book now
did get some predictable reactions of
from
tankies i suppose you could say and
other people who just have this
very very strong hostility to rights
and i don't know matt if you want to
speak to that quickly or if igor you had
any opinions about just like the
the sort of landscape of leftism online
and hostility and owned like um
like libs and i don't know i think that
there's this propensity and some
laughing circles to assume that
the most radical outlook uh is the one
that's best right uh and my kind of
counter to that is if you genuinely want
to be a radical you need to be a radical
on the authentic sense of the word uh
you know because the latin for
radical is radics uh which means rooted
and i think this is why
marxist boutique has borne out a lot
better uh
than the critiques of a lot of other
utopian socialists because he had a
dialectical
approach uh to society rather than just
saying everything is bad and we need to
do away with it and replace it with this
right and the reason why i'm very
critical of a lot of
socialists um and leftists who say we
just need to do away with liberalism
it's precisely because it's not a very
dialectical approach
right uh it doesn't recognize that
liberalism is
a historically situated ideology uh with
a certain material base
and if we're going to overcome its
limitations that we need to actually
first understand them
and recognize that any society that
we're going to build on top of it
is inevitably going to be as your
pointed out stamped
uh with the influence of this doctrine
and this particular way of doing things
right and a truly radical critique not
just doesn't just recognize that
uh but it also acknowledges that there
are certain features of the old society
that we're going to want to keep
both for normative and for historical
reasons and the
better apocrypha right uh and
this is just why i get frustrated right
and it's like it's kind of a drive for
purity it's like this this strange
there's like there's an interesting
psychological mechanism i feel like that
you could read through like lacan or
something like that that like you know
there's
it's this kind of like wanting this this
oppositional thinking to be like well
everything that's associated with that
is bad and i just want to like take and
and and establish this pure
moral high ground in a sense well the
ironic thing is uh i think that
a lot of these this mentality owes a lot
more to nature
than it does to somebody like marx right
because
there's just fantasy to think that uh
the
established order as it is is bad um
because i didn't create it
uh and therefore a radical critique or
an ever more radical fatigue because
it's sometimes put
uh involves trashing everything about
the establish the status quo
and suggesting how we're going to
utterly replace it with something
different right
yeah we've seen the impotence of these
kinds of critiques
for decades now uh where people put
forward ever more radical
critiques of the status quo uh
hypothesizing about speculative futures
that will never come
and none of it really amounts to
anything right and i think one of the
reasons that marx's
thinking has resonated with people for
such a long time is precisely because
a dialectical approach genuinely is
radical uh in the sense that it
historically situates the time period in
which he lives
and showcases how it is that we might
move away from that
in a way that seems realistic and
plausible
and that to me is a lot more radical
than just sitting there saying
we need to burn down the old to build
the new
and i think that a lot of progressives
really need to wean themselves off of
this kind of utopian
um mode of thinking about things
yeah you've already have thoughts about
like the landscape now
but i feel quite strongly about that one
one minor quibble with mad about
nietzsche because i have a soft spot for
nietzsche and i was standing my own
political proclivities and interests and
marx is that
even he recognizes in the genealogy of
morals that without slave morality human
beings wouldn't have that
that's true now his solution of course
that the new
the revaluation of all values and new
mass
master morality the future philosophers
i don't find very
helpful or for that matter very
practical uh so that's why
but thor appealing you know normative or
normative grounds
although a case could be made and has
been made that zeratustra descends
uh from the mountains in order to show
you know the abyss and
to to kind of reignite it that's a very
you could say
minority reading yeah of course but in
any case
in the genealogy of morals i think he
does sketch out kind of a more
historical genealogical approach
of how you know slave morality become
dominant
i think the challenge for marx is to
engage with nietzsche's to say well
actually we need a new
slave morality that will actually be
more consistent
and less hypocritical because nietzsche
and marx were both critic
critics of modernity in a sense as well
of course dialectics of uh suspicion or
whatever or no uh yeah is that what they
call it hermeneutics of suspicion that's
it yeah
right uh i think you know matt obviously
has more experience with this online
environment than i do i'm new to it but
i've i've
encountered it in person right yeah and
i think the best way
at least when we are in settings where
people are willing to listen
and engage in debate and dialogue and it
is occurred once i was involved
and gave presentations for the marx and
philosophy society in the uk
and we would have activists as well as
you know academics
and i gave this point criticizing pasha
carnis and then i had this chance why
are you so big on rights and i said
you know kind of why must we have rights
and so on this seems rather foreign
and i said well what will you have in
its place and then the individual in
question said it's not a fair question
i'm like it is a fair question because
you're posing this question to me and i
at least offer something in the way of
an answer
i think we have to once i mean we have
to take
criticism seriously but then we have to
challenge the people who are criticizing
to provide a better alternative
because yeah in some sense that shows
that we're actually respecting or
listening to what they're saying
that's a certain point right you can't
do that um
when it's at home and nothing more than
that i've also experienced that
i was actually called the tanki recently
i had to look up what that meant because
you know it has this is this is the
point about kind of invoking terms
out of context right so thank you
i was called a potential uh follower of
the straussian and also trot's case at
the same time
which led to a various humorous and
uplifting moments for me
as i you know teaching many courses so
you know i think
past a certain point if it's simply ad
hominem there's no point in engaging
with that
but for those of us who are committed to
a better world
right and also like me and having been
born in the former soviet union
we have a responsibility you know to
learn from the past we're talking about
human lives here
so i'll just repeat you know the point
that i made earlier about pashukanas
for him the legal theory was a question
of life and death
we have to we don't have to recreate you
know his the conditions and do it under
which he lived certainly we don't want
to do that
but we have to learn from the mistakes
of the past and when we continue to
theorize about
you know societies that won't have
room for conflicts where everyone will
agree
right well there'll be unity of social
purpose and while at the same time
simply dumping in a one-sided way on the
achievements many of which
by the way right came about as a result
of people on the left fighting for civil
liberties rights didn't fall from the
sky
so when people dump on rights
particularly i'm not talking about the
economic
rights in particular my economic rights
you know contractual rights and
freedom of contract but call them
positive or socio-economic rights as
well
people those individuals are dumping on
the legacy and the contributions of
those who fought for those things
when they didn't exist which is why i
spent a lot of time in the book actually
paying attention to specifically those
conditions
or those situations when rights were at
stake and what marx had to say about
them on the jewish question
was partially inspired because marx was
approached by
the leadership the delegation of the
rhineland jewish community
asking him to endorse a petition in
favor of
rights equal rights for the jews and he
says i'll do it i don't like
you know organized religion or judaism
but we have to punch as many holes as
possible and pressure the prussian state
and introduce right as many rational
views as we can what are those rational
views the defense of equal rights
for the jewish community that's one case
the next case is the 1848 revolutions
right where marx was actually involved
in that revolution and returned to
cologne and was tried uh was tried for
uh treason
and and tax refusal right because of the
illegitimacy of the reactionary state
that came to
so when that question emerges where did
marx stand with respect to rights
when the rights were actually at stake
it's absolutely clear where he stood
he stood in defense of civil rights and
liberties no one pays attention to that
all we remember from on the jewish
question mostly
is an anti-semitic diatribe apparently
which nonetheless was meant to
defend the rights of jews i'm not you
know i'm not i'm not uh
apologizing for marx's language i think
it was sure quite irresponsible
particularly the second essay
especially if we read it in the you know
in the aftermath of the holocaust and so
on but we can't blame marx for
everything
you know but it wasn't it was
irresponsible
uh from our present standpoint and what
we know about what happened
so i want to make make that point and
then finally right
uh the reactionary waves the fact that
marx was always a critic
of the autocratic uh authoritarian and
prussian
state right we tend to forget about that
right and we shouldn't because that's
what makes marx so relevant
to the 21st century because we're seeing
a relapse of that
and this is where i think those who are
committed to
the idea that the free development of
each as a condition for the free
development of all
should join forces in order to fight for
those things that are worthy
of safeguarding protecting and
ultimately expanding and we can't do
that
unless you know we work together to
defend the things that have been
accomplished achieved
by many members you know of the left
including the working class
uh and it's silly to think that we
should simply dump on something
without which angles and mark say a
working working class movement is just
not possible
without freedom of expression assembly
association
you see that in luxembourg's work as
well which i don't discuss in the book
so you know the fact of the matter is
you know we are liberated
from the experience and the tragedy the
accomplishments of the soviet union
because
again i don't see it in a one-sided way
uh it's you know there were many gains
made
in the early years of the russian
revolution radically liberal one could
say
uh but you know it just shows the
complexity
of what it means to try and work towards
realizing a new standard of right beyond
the narrow horizon of bourgeois right
so you know the ultimate point
interpretive point is that beyond the
narrow horizon there's a broader horizon
not no horizon as such that's what i'd
say
good i think that's a great place to end
uh igor thanks so much the book is
revisiting marx's critique of
liberalism rethinking justice legality
and rights from palgrave macmillan
it's a good book and uh
i thanks we can stop recording now right